So today I want to talk a little bit
more about probability distributions.
And specifically talk about what's called
continuous distributions, because there's
some caveat that you should be aware of
as you go forward in this class. So
here is a new prop, it's a nerf gun, they
actually should like this, and we have
a lot of those of Udacity. I want to
know, to do an experiment in which shoot a
projectile and somewhere hits the ground,
say between this location over here, and
this location over here, I just don't know.
So I call this A and B. The question I want
to raise is a tricky one,
consider any location X assume that the
angle of the new kind of somewhat random
and source the pressure behind the
projectile, what's the probability that
any specific XD might choose is the
correct one.